[Music]
I didn't going to sneak Thor Ragnarok
and getting surprised by the it tired
cast for a live version of the film
well Jane Corden actually made that
happen I love different sensory opening
this fans right well the movie is
projected to make over 400 million
dollars this weekend shattering the
worldwide box office record for the year
meanwhile Chris Hemsworth co-star is
shattering the illusion behind Chris's
bio workout videos Tessa was telling me
that in the gym she worked out with you
she said that you actually did a little
bit more grunting than you did work it
out yeah well you know it's more about
showing up than actually doing the word
him and his whole team his stunt double
as well they've they're so grunty it's
just like like it's not that hard I know
you're making it sound harder than it is
it's about tricking people it's it's a
world of make-believe and I'm an actor
and so something acted apart and the
rest is CJ especially thanks yeah you
don't get abs like that with special
effects but Chris's workouts they're not
just about getting a god of thunder
shape they're also about staying humble
your school mate is is your trainer is
that right yeah give me four we've known
each other since we were this big about
four years old you have people who kind
of remind you don't be an idiot you know
this is this is what's real this is who
you are not who you think they went
under UN look great dude Thunder in thor
ragnarok Chris must defeat the goddess
of death played by Cate Blanchett you
know in my seat this is unlikely
accomplice no Hulk played by Mark
Ruffalo
there was a scene when you go from Hulk
to banner and you're sitting there
shirtless in front of Chris Hemsworth I
was doing push-ups and sit-ups and I was
on just before I was doing the scene I
was doing anything good yeah no one's
Chris Hemsworth listen is the guy who
likes to work out a little bit I mean I
can't imagine going up next to the god
of thunder like that well done
[Music]